“It’s time to bring our
people back home.”
“...to end America’s
longest war.”
“The US will soon complete its
withdrawal of forces from Afghanistan.”
“Taliban fighters have
flooded the capital.”
“There are American-made weapons
in the hands of Taliban fighters.”
“Many of the Afghans trying to escape
actually helped American armed forces.”
“It was quite clear that
it was going to come to this.”
BIDEN: I stand squarely
behind my decision.
After 20 years, there was never a
good time to withdraw US forces.
AZMAT KHAN: People are
glued to their TV screens.
It's chaotic.
It is a mess.
But to really understand how we got here,
we have to go back to the beginning.
So, for many Americans,
Afghanistan is the “good war.”
My name is Azmat Khan.
I’m an investigative reporter.
They see the war in Iraq as
the one that was unjustified,
going after something
that didn't exist,
these weapons of
mass destruction.
And they see Afghanistan as the place
that was shortchanged because of Iraq.
Michael McKinley.
I was ambassador in Afghanistan.
The decision to invade Afghanistan was
directly related to the attacks on 9/11.
“Osama bin Laden publicly
declared war on the US.”
“He openly bragged about his
direct involvement in planning 9/11.”
AZMAT KHAN: Osama bin
Laden was in Afghanistan.
BUSH: On my orders, the United States
military has begun strikes.
AZMAT KHAN: But once the bombing
began, and in the lead-up to it,
it was no longer just about,
we want to have bin Laden.
It was about
the Taliban state.
LAURA BUSH: The plight of
women and children in Afghanistan
is a matter of deliberate
human cruelty.
The fight against terrorism is also a fight
for the rights and dignity of women.
AZMAT KHAN: There were actually offers
to turn over bin Laden by the Taliban.
And the United States refused.
They wanted a surrender
directly to the United States.
Now, shortly after the bombing campaign
started, the Taliban fell fairly quickly.
And by April of 2002, it was
very apparent to the Americans
that they couldn't just sweep in,
overthrow a regime, and walk away.
You needed to build
a new government.
This nation-building program that
really prioritized counterterrorism.
BUSH: We expect cells of
trained killers to try to regroup,
and try to undermine Afghanistan's
efforts to build a lasting peace.
AZMAT KHAN: This idea that, listen,
we're going to take the gloves off,
and we're really going
to eradicate al-Qaeda.
OBAMA: Good evening.
Tonight, I can report to the
American people, and to the world,
that the United States has conducted
an operation that killed Osama bin Laden,
the leader of al Qaeda and
a terrorist who’s responsible
for the murder of thousands of
innocent men, women, and children.
MICHAEL MCKINLEY: The decrease in
troop presence really dates from 2011.
There was a sense that, overall,
the threat of a terrorist attack
against the United States from
Afghanistan was greatly diminished.
Part of what American forces in
Afghanistan were doing became
providing more formalized training,
building up equipment,
providing intelligence support,
eventually providing air support...
AZMAT KHAN: Afghan soldiers were supported
by US aircraft that would fire on insurgents.
Really, it was just air power that
allowed the Afghan government
to retain this tenuous hold in places where
they weren't necessarily very popular.
MICHAEL MCKINLEY: The Afghan
security forces weren't evolving
quite in the manner that was anticipated.
AZMAT KHAN: At the same time, you also saw
billions of dollars in reconstruction money
pouring into a country without the kind of
infrastructure to really handle that kind
of money.
That means building
health clinics.
It means building
schools, bridges, roads.
And more than that,
that kind of reconstruction money,
coupled with America's
counterterrorism goals,
was really
a toxic mix.
Partnering with very corrupt
warlords, or local strongmen,
who, in exchange for allowing you
to build a school on this land,
you would give us the contract
for the health clinic right next door.
I had US soldiers tell me things like, yeah,
he was a warlord, but he was our warlord.
Most media coverage from Afghanistan
that Americans might hear
often comes from urban cities,
particularly Kabul.
“From Kabul,
Afghanistan.”
“In the Afghan
capital, Kabul.”
But across the rural countryside,
support for the Taliban gained ground,
because of this massive
campaign of airstrikes, of bombings,
much of which have had
high civilian death tolls.
The Taliban had
been defeated.
And yet the American presence in Afghanistan
brought them back from the dead.
MICHAEL MCKINLEY: In the 2013-2014 period,
the Taliban began to regain its footing.
It was clear that every year
they were making some advances,
and they were operating primarily
in rural and depopulated areas.
AZMAT KHAN: US intelligence was either
incredibly misrepresented or incredibly flawed.
MICHAEL MCKINLEY: There was
this growing concern, for example,
with what is commonly
called “ghost soldiers.”
How many soldiers were
actually on the rolls?
Was it 330,000? Or was it several
tens of thousands lower than that?
And the real issue related to
whether soldiers felt they were
fighting for a government
that represented them.
AZMAT KHAN: It's talked about often
that the Afghan government,
and the particularly
the president,
was not coming to the
negotiating table with the Taliban.
“President Trump ordering
a drawdown of troops.”
“All US troops should leave
Afghanistan by the end of the year.”
“A very unpopular war
here in the United States.”
“President Joe Biden has
decided the United States
has seen enough of
the war in Afghanistan.”
AZMAT KHAN: So when the Biden
administration announced that
they would be continuing
Trump's plan to withdraw,
many Afghanistan watchers were
poised for the Taliban to gain ground.
The United States, which has been
providing air power to Afghan forces,
now, all of a sudden, that's no longer going to
be something that Afghan forces can rely on.
We saw them sweep through districts
in places that were more rural
and we saw an escalation
of that in May of 2021.
But I don't think anyone expected it
to gain ground as quickly as it did.
“It’s clear who is
now in charge.”
“The Taliban is
sweeping the country.”
“Here in Kabul, the city has
collapsed. There’s no real security.”
“As the Taliban solidify their control
of the city and the country...”
“...the Afghans who went above and beyond
to help American servicemembers
are stuck in limbo.”
AZMAT KHAN: A large reason that many
Afghans worked with the Americans,
or other foreigners, was that many of them
wanted a better life for their families,
and hoped that it would one day
lead to their being able to leave.
And so, watching the Taliban
come as suddenly as it did,
knowing what their
futures might be,
it is a failure on the part
of the US government.